jours annonce annula bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
l'om est donc se dit inquiète une
troisième vague épidémique est imminente
en afrique
est ce que vous partagez ce constat
absolument
le nombre de carats jones sont en
afrique du sud un triplé ouais
journellement
donc nous sommes un look de cette
troisième vague
oui il faut plutôt se préparer en
afrique et ceux des hôpitaux sont bien
préparés les centres de vaccination sont
prêts et des centaines de sans nouvelles
malheureusement il ya un manque de
vaccins
justement sur le terrain qu'est ce que
vous constatez exactement vous dans dans
les hôpitaux ou dans votre cabinet dans
mon cabinet je constate une augmentation
du nombre de cas comme je disais toi
quatre fois plus de patients sont
contaminés oui exactement pas mal de
gens se sont fait vacciner
mais comme je vous disais il ya un grand
manque de vaccins nous attendions des
vaccins de johnson & johnson mais
malheureusement une contamination de ces
vaccins nous devons concevoir une
millions de douces et chacun à lui
annulé un peu plus de 2 milliards de
doses de vaccins ont été délivrés à ce
jour dans le monde dans 215 pays ou
territoires ont peut-être fait israël 59
% de la population qui a reçu au moins
une dose
suivent le canada 59 % le royaume-uni 58
le chili les états unis l'union
européenne
mais l'afrique est elle à la traîne vous
parler de ce manque de vaccins sur le
continent africain
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquer
premiers mois nous avions commencé à
vacciner
astrazeneca le vario est apparue donc
assali cadieux est renvoyée vendus à
d'autres pays
nous avons commencé à vacciner que
johnson & johnson et puis comme vous le
savez il ya eu des problèmes de
coagulation s'était interrompu pendant
quelques semaines et une nouvelle
commande a été faite pour le challenge
en scène et a été interrompu à nouveau à
cause de contamination contamination
dans le laboratoire aux états unis le
programme cots watelet ce qu'il joue son
rôle selon vous je pense que oui je
pense que oui tout étoile à fond je vous
élire s confie vous je reformule la
question est-ce qu'il joue suffisamment
son rôle ses programmes puisque vous
déploré un manque de doses sur le
continent africain
c'est absolument ça le manque de doses
vraiment appris que passer en dernier
lieu
je suppose qu'ils sont pris aussi un
petit peu tard l'afrique de succès s'ils
avouent s'y est pris aussi et à une
raison je pense pour laquelle nous avons
un manque de vaccins aujourd'hui on sait
que la semaine dernière il y avait
manuel macron qui s'est rendu en afrique
du sud il a rencontré son homologue
sud-africain cyril ramaphosa les deux
hommes qui ont échangé justement sur la
vaccination pour l'afrique et les doses
qui devait
augmenter pour les pays en développement
est ce que vous attendez vous attendez
dans les prochains jours dans les
prochaines semaines à ce qu'il y ait
plus de doses sur le continent africain
écoutez je pense quand bassam surtout
s'attendre face au vaccin qui vont
arriver l'étranger des états unis
je pense ça va prendre du temps avant de
relancer la fabrication locale
l'afrique du sud produisent et ses
vaccins jusqu'en 2001 il a été
interrompu pour des raisons delà du coût
de production mais la licence
apparemment a été relancée de la part de
l'europe et des états unis pour
commencer à fabriquer des vaccins en
afrique du sud
je raconte du temps merci à mon seigneur
d'avoir répondu à la question je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste belge installée à
johannesburg en afrique du sud